foreign
Houston Texas hey Eric what's up
hi uh Dave this um I just started
listening to you not too long ago I have
a friend that uh that did your program
and you know is out of debt uh I have a
question my wife and I were um we're
she believes in having no debt so we're
going into this
um but I've already you know calculated
how much you know you know a credit card
loan I that I have
um here's the thing I we have five
properties right uh three of them are
rented out one of them is where we live
and another one I'm going to start
running it out because you know it was
kind of like out in the country weekend
but we don't get out there so I'm either
gonna put it up for Airbnb or rent it
out to someone that lives out in that
area
once when I've added all my my debt I
have two mortgages right two loans for
but five properties but two loans for to
pay two of these properties do I treat
those two loans that uh as part of a
snowball you know do I lump them in with
that or I mean how would I how to tackle
that your personal residence is paid for
yes okay how much non-mortgage debt do
you have
uh 20 21. cool what's your household
income
um so my wife just started working again
so I make 80
um but my wife makes uh she's
transitioning to a position that
hopefully will get her you know 50 60s
but right now I mean I'm creating it as
if she's bringing in 35 a year so I
would say you don't have to treat it
anyway it's just what she is making
written making so yeah right now she you
make 80 and it sounds like she's gonna
make 60 or at 140. you're gonna pay off
20 very quickly if you freaking behave
and lean into it and uh now your other
two properties your home is paid for but
your other two properties what's the
balance on those debts so uh I actually
got a home equity loan on the property I
live in it was paid for and then I guess
oh so your home is not paid for
so the one I live in right now yeah
that's your home yeah yes it's not paid
for
no it has a loan on it yes okay how much
uh one
60. okay cool and what's the other debt
the other mortgage uh 143. cool all
right what we would do is put those both
in baby step six
okay and address those as you get there
and I would pay off your house first
then I would pay off the rental
okay what did you say is the 21
000 in debt credit cards uh it's credit
cards uh and I've got I've got
um about 13 in the bank that I'm gonna
put 12 into okay um that and then um I
when I do my taxes I always get money
back because I deduct more I don't know
if that's a smart thing to do but no
it's not
um so I'm I'm you're loaning the
government money all year with no
interest
and they give it back to you and you act
like Santa Claus lives in DC
yes yes yeah so go ahead and go ahead
and set your withholding up properly
where you don't get a refund and you
don't have to pay but you try to aim it
as close to your actual proper amount to
be withheld uh because a refund is
simply a loan interest-free loan to the
government
because he said something
they said his wife is about no debt and
I'm curious has he decided that he's
about no debt because that's a very
interesting distinction that his wife
doesn't believe in debt does he I mean
because this that's quite a few
different loans and and mortgages
he had decided to get out of that and
then she got on board maybe I
misunderstood but I I hope that would be
my question is just making sure you all
are awesome this is the guy who went and
got a home equity loan to buy rental
property and that put us home at risk
again so yeah but yeah you just drop
that all over all your real estate stuff
over into baby step six and get it paid
off there the great news is you make
good money and if you lean into this you
can be 100 debt free houses and
everything in just a few years you'll be
amazed